they tested the audience they asked all
the questions and then at the end they
says there anything else we should tell
and this guy slowly raised his hand and
he said I snuck a bag of Skittles into
the screening and the entire time I was
like this so if you make a lot of noise
in the theater you're gonna think you're
gonna die you may be was so scary
thank you yeah it's a it's a new rare
thing for me to when people go your
movie maybe not breathe that's a good
thing what did you think of the premise
when you first heard about it I
instantly knew he was on to something I
remember the exact moment I was like I
was nobody done this before they haven't
done it before we can it do it it's
about a family that can't make any noise
and you have to figure out why and I
thought that's one of the best
one-liners I've ever heard what was it
like having John behind the lens or on
set with you amazing and we were so
aligned in what we felt about the film
we trust each other a lot we don't have
that sort of diplomacy that wastes so
much time in some ways by trying to be
polite I'd be like that doesn't work and
and he'd be like I see what you're doing
it's not working and I was like okay
silence in horror films it's usually the
scariest part because you know something
is coming so when you have a movie that
is so much silence how do you still
create that sense of tension is it just
more silence less silent exactly I mean
it's a really good question for me it
was so much fun to play with that it was
so scary
before we went in to shoot - how are you
gonna maintain a level of tension
without being able to talk and doing all
these different things and yet then
after a few days of shooting you
realized what I was most scared of is
actually our superpower you get to play
with all these incredible sounds and all
these incredible moments of pulling
sound out and why and it was it was
really a lot of fun
[Music]